che bello quando ci sono questi
videogiochi che partono con questa
musica del menu che prodotti né briano
l'anima da tutti ragazzi benvenuti a
questo video sono vari generi oggi se un
sub barbershop che sarebbe un videogioco
dove devo tagliare peli pubici della
faccia alle persone perché le persone
anni pelli fa c'era una nuova partita
che siamo aperti era certo che siamo
presso il bar vieta tra l'altro io io
che sono sono passato attraverso il
bancone cazzo di barbiere sono solo un
fantasma cavo nuovo ti sei david seria
non funziona più come una volta ragazzi
che i negozi chiudono e quando aprono
entrare agli cliente non ha il negozio
era chiuso e cliente stava già dentro
hai dormito bene susta sedia frate oggi
zio fa vivi insegna a radere un uomo
nella vita tutti quanti hanno bisogno di
imparare questa tecnica allora anche le
banche le signore si prenderà
esattamente così la si fa entrare la
lama dentro il mento del party del
paziente chiamava così si fa su e giù
finché non è così si esatto rimangono
tutti pelucchi ma è normale perchè fa
figo fa molto figo dopodiché si tagliano
i baffi nel mezzo solo ed esclusivamente
nel mezzo effettua dalla bassetto ana
qua la togliamo che non piace a nessuno
qua lasciamo un piccolo solco che che fa
figo
eccola finito ragazzi direi che avrebbe
bebè è bello eh va beh questo è un
taglio alla faringe cia nel senso vedi
che che charme ragazzi ff di figo nel
senso che è giusto più avanti ancora non
sempre con il primo effetto effetto le
fa vi si legge su fe dei favi cetti sto
studiando la cosa va a questa l'aria che
stava mai che il clan o e luglio e
hitler e beh beh beh credo che sia il
lavoro più bello che abbia mai fatto
fino adesso e poi ragazzi non lo sapete
ma la barba in un uomo a un aumento a
tante cose aumenta la sec saggina
inoltre avere la barba aumenta del 50
per cento la possibilita di trovare
camicia da boscaiolo se aprite l'armadio
se siete sovrappensiero e vi toccate il
mento ragionate del 20 per cento in più
insomma la barba è
serve ragazzi serve a tutti quindi anche
alle donne ragazze fatevi crescere la
barba che non avete idea di quanto sia
fingono averla li sto cambiando gli
attrezzi davanti all'occhio è una cosa
ovvero come cazzo è possibile che una
persona vada dal barbiere a chiedergli
mi fai un taglio dove sembra una capra
che cazzo cioè per una capra vero
accontentiamo su cristiano facciamoli la
barba da chiara però cazzola patata non
arriva a frate fatto c'è nel senso va
bene per calcare però spero che ti
piaccia a 0 perfetto
mi ispiro perché non so come fa allora
proviamo a fare la barba di wolverine
tommy gli assomiglia guardalo la vacca e
uomo ma che uomo a tutto sommato
somiglia abbastanza mancati dovreste
averla grigia barba zio però hai dei
begli occhi compensa e poi i capelli da
johnny bravo zio vogliamo mettere ecco è
questa questa basta che lo lascio come
ed è così è l'ultimo uomo al quale
dobbiamo copiare la barba che dobbiamo
assolutamente farlo è soltanto uno
mourinho che i chicchi che cosa è che
vinca ti arriva fino a terra quindi
ragazzi
l'unico modo per riuscire a tagliare
così tanto la barba ad un uomo è questo
caracas e mi somiglia se si prendesse
gioco dal al punto giusto non è così
facile perché cazzo fare la barbara in
modo giusto difficilissimo cioè i
ragazzi vorrei avere la barba veramente
per farmela non so cosa ci si cosa si
prova a farsi la barba non mai fatta io
non ho gli ormoni da uomo sono una donna
non ciò mi cresce [ __ ] questi
bacchettini da mafioso cinese vabbè e
questo dovrebbe essere di homer somigli
un pochettino ea livello di barba a
posto e non che cosa cazzo vuoi ti dico
sì fatta da solo come cazzo fai a
chiamare un taglio di zappa che cazzo
sei pasquale pratico ma allora ascoltami
no non ti volevo in l'occhio non lo
tocchiamo guarda sei più un gioco di de
carli premiamo benissimo così è un figo
massimo ho preso il massimo di sé di
quel di centrare il bersaglio con la
lama non so che cosa vuol dire non vi
sposereste quest'uomo anche se siete
maschi ho preso una come cazzo fanno mai
preso manco a scuola da ragazzi tg
no ho sbagliato grazie a cliccato
bellissimo e mi ha pure dato dei soldi
terrà in questa entra entrare in negozio
si siede non faccio un cazzo e mi da 40
dollari grazie frate che il tizio si
chiama alvin harris ci mettevano lacci
all'inizio inventava calvin harris e
facciamoli i dj che per fare i soldi
facili sto gioco dopo che il frico
finisce solo finisce mi pagano non
pensavo fosse così facile fare il
barbiere ragazza in una stronzata
io credo che con tutta la barba che ho
tagliato oggi possiamo farci il campo da
calcio
c'è veramente una tristezza diciamo no
al maltrattamento dei peli c'è una cosa
tristissima a un bacio più lungo
dell'altro ma chi se ne fotte facciamo
cacciamo corciano
ecco adesso più e più e più lungo
l'altro e che cazzo
minchia con le misure madonna ecco basta
ronca carlo cazzo ma te lo tieni ti
lascio dopo il pezzo di baffo lì perché
fa figo non lo sai tu non sai la moda
come valeva che gioco ci ha creduto mai
creduto aggrava non ci credo tutto
calcolato la gara il baffo qua che è che
fa figo cioè noi ma che ho preso pure
altro ragazzino non squadrato alla
perfezione è bellissimo
credo sia un capo lo voglio vedere che
questo quanto mi dà fatti mi ha dato un
cazzo è che non sai apprezzare l'arte ai
ragazzi con quello che l'episodio è
stato istruttivo perché avete imparato
tutti come fare la barba specialmente le
signorine fatti e pratica sul bug sul
bar dove andate dal vostro babbo e di
trivago ho imparato a fare la barba da
farisei e gli fate vedere come si fa la
barba perché così che si fa
ricordatevelo per tutta la vita che
vedono insegnato io ei ragazzi spero che
il video come l'ho lasciato per cristian
spero che vito vi sia piaciuto cosa
sento se vi sia piaciuto al trattamento
è un mi piace non mi piace per il taglio
di parma di fa vj che minchia che che
barba
io sono uomo dentro e ricordati ragazzi
che l'importante non è essere belli
fuori ma belli dentro quindi
l'importante non è averla barba fuori ma
averla dice va bene spero che avete sia
piaciuto a casa i ragazzi si vedeva
piaciuta sottomento è un mi piace anche
la pagina di facebook e condivido la
trascrizione sono travestiti scrittrici
villa orso video e barba di sera bel
tempo si spera chi di barba ferisce di
barba ma che cazzo nessuno avrebbe la
regalia